what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to
young boy never broke again white teeth
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification
bell as you guys know i'm trying to get
to 20 000 subscribers this month
and each and every one of you helps and
then if you ring the notification bell
you're actually going to be notified of
my daily videos
um i wanted to also thank the subscriber
that sent me this clip
on instagram as you guys know if you
want to submit clips for me to react to
send them to me on
[Music]
instagram
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
okay he's letting you know that he is a
ladies man
so he's he's letting you know that like
because of his vibe
his look um his money the ladies
really enjoy his presence
go home and take my meds
[Music]
they don't like me shawty told me that
she feeling she wanna
[Music]
okay again he's kind of reiterating the
same point like
now he's letting you know what sexual
positions
that he would like to engage in
um apparently she the girl on top i
i'm not
[Music]
wait so did he say he has diamonds on
his white teeth
that seems like a waste of money
like if i were you i'm not going to tell
you how to spend your money okay but if
i were you
i would say invest into real estate
maybe the stock market i don't that's
just me
don't excite me
[Music]
calling them on my way keep a mess when
i don't leave no trace keep it man's run
only no case hop out aim and i swing
that drink taking a light swing around
my weight
dominate like imma click on bang down
with it like i'm a reclaimed fake
diamond piece
eyes on chinese
[Music]
she [ __ ] with there are a lot of
girls in this video he he's not lying
about
his interactions with women
okay so he's letting you know that he's
not into like the basic girls like he
likes girls
that are different which is good so i
think he's saying to value women for
their personality
i got cancer yeah she bad she got asked
me
[Music]
she like me now she know that basic [ __ ]
don't excite me
okay so in terms of this video i'm going
to give it
you as you guys know i do scales of like
one to five and on scale of one to five
i give it
i'm sorry like a two it just wasn't my
vibe i didn't feel like it was that
different
from like the other rap songs that i've
listened to uh it was
catchy and so i will like give it that
like i felt myself like shimmy and
bobbing my head a little bit so i did
enjoy that
but just because like i feel like the
video itself was kind of basic
and so was the song um sorry
nba young boy fans but let me know in
the comments if you guys agree or you
disagree
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification
bell